you know I was getting shot at it's like
I can't imagine I was just talking about
lack of empathy I can't imagine being in
a situation where I'm on television and
I'm saying things that are so removed
from the truth right like I I can't wrap
my head around them well Hillary did the
same thing well she's a congenital iris
as she was referred to by the New York
Times back in the day and and rightly so
but she people forget this she did talk
about a fire fight that she was involved
was under sniper fire and the worst
thing about that that people didn't give
a [ __ ] about she said when she was in
Bosnia she was under sniper fire it's
like wait a minute we were throwing the
Secret Service on the bus cuz what kind
of secret surface is gonna let the first
lady run under sniper fire and there's
been and she just basically did a double
talk around that but she's got a lot of
whoppers in her name she said she was
named after Hillary Edmund Hillary even
though he climbed Mount Everest after
she was born so she says I mean amazing
I love that woman I love her so much
she's the funniest person on earth
she's like a slinky she's always falling
down the stairs
how dare you yeah she's uh it's an odd
duck it's it's one of those things where
women want a woman to be President so
bad they want one for the team so bad
and then there's so many people from the
left I think she has the best chance of
beating Trump or whoever is on the right
that they want her so about there
they're willing to exonerate her right
I'm so many different horrendous things
one of the things I always point out
like people want to talk progressive
they want you want to talk you know
being left-wing and she didn't even
believe in gay marriage until 2013 the
best part was she was on NPR which is
this far-left far-right fringe
organization by NPR Terry Gross and
Terry Gross says you used to be against
gay marriage you know your husband
passed DOMA which made it a federal law
that gay marriage won't be recognized by
the federal government and you changed
your position like how did that happen
was it because Americans became
Hillary's like well America changed our
point of view she doesn't know I
understand Americans change their point
of view what was your mental process and
she goes no Terry you're saying that I
changed my mind for political purposes
and that's not true and I was she starts
yelling at her and it's like holy [ __ ]
you're on NPR and you think they're to
right-wing for you because they're
calling you on your [ __ ] you [ __ ]
loon but the worst part is I had Juanita
Broderick on my show two weeks ago and
she's the one who accused Clinton of
raping her hmm and I asked her who's
worse Clinton or Hillary she said
Hillary she said she's the one who knew
what was going on and let him get away
with it so that was scary to hear Wow
the the the thing that got me was when
they were confronting bill recently
about Monica Lewinsky and they asked him
do you owe her an apology right and he
was like anybody thinks about God out of
that free you're crazy
let me tell you something I was I left
the White House millions dollars and
yeah and they stole the furniture and
they had to return it yeah they stole
the what they looted the White House
there to return all the [ __ ] they stole
come on there's a book called final exit
written by Barbara Olson who died in
9/11 and it's all about they [ __ ]
stole everything real all the staff also
popped out all the double use of the
keyboards so the George Bush office
people couldn't use them yeah they went
out there like [ __ ] that's actually
kind of funny that's a that's a good
little [ __ ] you yeah but the idea that
this guy would in especially in today's
political climate and dealing with me
too and all the the the various scandals
that have been going on rapists exposed
that this guy who if all that [ __ ] was
going on today we likely either be under
indictment or at the very least under
heavy investigation yeah for sexual
assault but because it's so long ago it
seems to be like this weird sort of gray
area that he's saying I don't know her
an apology you know if anybody thinks
that I wasn't punished like you weren't
punished like you're worth hundreds of
millions of dollars now how there are
you worth so much money now
one of the greatest things I remember at
the time this has been forgotten the
press likes to throw this under the rug
super under rug they said at first a
Monica Lewinsky was a stalker all of
Clinton's goons would go on the news
channels at the time say she's a lunatic
she's a stalker they never had an affair
and you're sitting there that she's like
23 how the [ __ ] do you stalk a president
like that does make any sense if it
wasn't for that dress let's keep that in
mind if she didn't have physical
evidence nothing would have happened to
him and she would be regarded as a loon
to this day and she'd be treating a
complete pariah they were ready it would
have never went public with it it was
she was immersed here we go pom no no
that she can star found her he
subpoenaed her yeah but it was because
of that woman in a trap Linda Tripp
right it was her coaxing her to keep the
dress yes just keep the dress but go
public with this and talk about she was
outed by Drudge remember was that before
that before Linda Tripp was doing all
this later in the trip was she coaching
her through the whole thing Linda Tripp
was coaching her privately this is all
private Drudge broke it because the
press wasn't covering it and they didn't
know what to do because this is a big
moment internet history where they're
like this website is revealing
information and now we're gonna talk
about and I thought that was also coming
from Linda Tripp and I thought Linda
Tripp you're the leaping the
conversations Linda Tripp was taping the
conversations I don't know how I know
Drudge was the one who made all this
[ __ ] public maybe she was being
subpoenaed privately thought she was
going to Drudge and she was leaking in
from a madam is that true can you look
at about that I don't think Linda Tripp
was leaking to Drudge well maybe she was
I thought the story was I don't know
though I thought the story was that she
was coaching Monica Lewinsky and trying
to get her to go public with it that's
possible when Monica didn't go public
the trash forced throughout the class
and she also did it without Monica's
consent as far as the recorder that was
trechie went to jail for it did she or
she was at least arrested
something happened yeah she was a very
least arrested for recording that
consent but that my point was like him
said on television like the lack of
insight the lack of objectivity is a
lack of personal objectivity that he's
getting asked his question do you owe
her apology that he can't say look I
made a mistake I shouldn't have done it
right it was a bad thing to do and
especially a bad thing to do to a 20
year old girl and have her exposed like
that I wasn't close to my daughter's age
yeah and for him to not say that this
like some serious sociopathic [ __ ]
involved and he's never I mean that's
his MO he never ever but also if you're
apologizing there you're probably
legally culpable right because they were
gonna get him for perjury
so Paul an apologies and acknowledgement
possibly from a I mean they pulled his
legal license because of this that was
part of the deal you know left the White
House that's right that's right I forgot
about that yeah the whole thing's a mess
and then and then when Hillary's asked
about it was that a some sort of abuse
of power
she's like no because their results
Monica
Winsky was an adult she was in
comparison to him but it's almost like
[ __ ] present so there are the only
time there's an abuse of power is when
children are involved yeah like what the
Friday talk about is crazy that makes no
sense but not only that that is the
biggest is the between an intern and the
later of the world right I mean there's
no bigger gap right forget about like
studio executive and actress you know
like that's that's tiny in comparison to
the leader of the world and an intern
and at the time all the feminists ran
interference for him the only one who
did it was the craziest one Andrea
Dworkin and she goes we know he's a
rapist Bruce Weber Neena Broderick we
know this was sexual harassment assault
sexual harassment and everyone's
covering for him and you guys are being
complete hypocrites it's crazy it's
crazy that they're willing to do that
it's tribalism I know but it's so
fascinating when you see it's so blatant
yeah